una esperanza de Justicia una
organización de defensa de Derechos
Humanos la fundación cluny para la
justicia denunció a las fuerzas de
seguridad de Venezuela ante un tribunal
argentino la fundación invoca el
principio de jurisdicción universal y la
falta de garantías para que presuntos
crímenes de lesa humanidad sean
investigados y procesados en Venezuela
no estamos hablando de casos aislados o
no se tratan de violaciones de Derechos
Humanos aisladas sino que hay una
creemos que una política de estado en
Venezuela hay una sistematicidad donde
vemos que no es solo una persona de
cometer los delitos sino que hay una
cadena de Mando donde se dan órdenes el
esfuerzo de la fundación creada por la
abogada de Derechos Humanos a Marc luni
recibió el apoyo de amnistía
internacional
las víctimas que hoy han denunciado
crímenes de lesa humanidad han confiado
en Argentina sus esperanzas de Justicia
los tribunales argentinos tienen
jurisdicción constitucional sobre estos
crímenes no por el lugar donde fueron
cometidos o por quién sino porque dañan
a la humanidad en su conjunto Esperamos
que la justicia Argentina esté a la
altura del desafío y mantenga su
tradición histórica de juzgar y
sancionar a los responsables de estos
crímenes a todos los niveles y es que
Argentina ya ha aplicado con
anterioridad el principio de
jurisdicción universal tribunales de ese
país se han pronunciado en torno a
crímenes el régimen franquista en España
e investigan el genocidio contra la
etnia rojilla en miamar la Corte Penal
Internacional abrió una causa formal
para investigar presuntos crímenes
contra la humanidad durante el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro y la misión de
determinación de hechos en la ONU
documentó ejecuciones extrajudiciales
desapariciones forzadas detenciones
arbitrarias tortura y tratos crueles
cometidos en Venezuela desde 2014